about a year ago I released a video
called the problem with budget cards to
this day that particular video is my
longest video and also my second best
performing video in terms of views it's
also wildly unpopular compared to
literally everything else I've released
the like to dislike proportion is an
abysmal 77% for context my second lowest
is around 95% and a brief look at the
comments section indicates that a lot of
people take issue with various things
contained within the video I've asked
myself a number of times if I should do
something with that video is the video
truly enough of a departure from the
quality of the rest of my work to
Warrant some sort of action a note in
the description or a pinned comment
saying that I enlightened future Alex
disavow the contents of the video and up
until now I would always come to the
conclusion that the answer is no my
running narrative to myself has been
that it's a largely fine video and that
the reason people reacted the way they
did comes down to some poor wording here
and there along with my choice to
frontload the most controversial
argument in the video I figured this was
likely Amplified by an especially Saucy
thumbnail along with the slow pacing and
droning sluggish delivery that
characterized my first three videos
however I haven't really put much
thought into the arguments themselves
and now that a year has passed I want to
do just that I am here revisiting that
video along with its central question
are cheap powerful cards a problem was I
on to something or flat out wrong or
somewhere in between in order to answer
that I'm going to first summarize what
that video is saying and you can skip
three minutes ahead if you're already
familiar with the contents of that
video soing is a powerful Mana artifact
printed very early in Magic's history it
was banned in Legacy and restricted in
vintage leading to it commanding a
moderate but affordable price for
players in the lightly played casual
format of Commander which was slowly
gaining steam during the 2000s due to
some players consider considering it a
staple it was printed in all five decks
in the first Commander set in 2011
however if being a staple is a flawed
argument for reprinting it because the
card was only a staple due to its
affordable price itself a result of it
not being legal in a large format
printing a set for Commander would
naturally grow the format grow the
demand for soling and without a reint
the card's price would be pushed in line
with that of similar fast Mana artifacts
such as manac Crypt rendering it
likewise a tool for the power Gamers I
believe the format would be better if
things had played out this way some have
argued that it should be banned but that
chip has sailed given the number of
reprints it has seen however soling
still poses an interesting question what
is the effect of cards with wildly
mismatched price and power level for one
they warp how players look at other
cards and this affects how many cards of
a given type players will run some
players might decide how many cards of a
given type to run ahead of time but most
won't instead players will add the best
options within their budget and then a
lot of them will notice the rapidly
worsening power to money ratio and stop
adding them at a certain point even if
running more of that type of card would
be better for their Deck with vegetables
like interaction and ramp it's easy to
distinguish the better options versus
worse options but when you get to
fuzzier more synergistic cards it's more
difficult to distinguish card quality
because analyzing them often requires
thinking about a variety of other cards
and different situations this leads to
players adding a handful of the most
powerful vegetable Staples and then
overloading on synergistic cards leading
to Decks that are crammed with win more
cards but lack a lot of the basic
building blocks that lead to a deck
consistently performing well in addition
to cards that pack a high power level
compared to their price a related type
of card that can cause problems is
expensive Staples that are already in
one's collection and which are thus free
to add as an example in my mid power
Maria Voltron deck I initially added
sord of Forge and Frontier but ended up
cutting it as it felt out of place it
pumped up the de's power level but
without solving any of the deck's
existing weaknesses making the deck less
well-rounded overall as another example
there are a lot of very powerful
graveyard synergies out there but the
game is also filled with extremely
powerful Silver Bullet graveyard hate
this means that upgrading a mid-power
graveyard deck can backfire putting it
in competition with Decks that will
likely be running cards with the
capability to totally dismantle an
unprepared graveyard deck and leading to
a less consistent play experience as
another example choosing to Run infinite
combos or other powerful strategies will
draw attacks and interaction for
opponents who are in the no and this can
be a problem if a player isn't prepared
to deal with this hate if your deck has
a wide range of power levels in its
potential plays opponents will often be
wary and default to attacking you even
if the average power level of your deck
is lower than that of some opposing
decks conclusion sing is upsettingly
powerful but isn't getting banned you
should figure out the correct number of
things you need in a particular category
ahead of time and avoid loading up too
hard on synergistic with more stuff
sometimes the theoretically most
powerful option out there won't be the
most powerful option for your deck and
sometimes the most powerful option for
your deck won't be the best idea for the
types of games you want to play I don't
run tourament of Hailfire in my Turbo
ramping glissa deck because I don't want
my opponents to equate me having a lot
of lands with an immediate game loss Q
time machine gag the video is over okay
so that is the problem with budget cards
condensed down into a piy 3-minute
summary with a year of additional
experience in writing video making and
playing Commander what do I think about
this video's arguments well past the
4minute introduction C ction they're
mostly fine if a little unfocused the
second section of the video where I talk
about the effect of other cards Being
Framed negatively by Cheap powerful
cards I maybe overstate the social
dynamics at play a little bit as I had
the tendency to do in some of my earlier
videos however a lot of my theorizing
here does line up with observations I've
had playing commander and looking at
deck lists people do tend to overrate
synergistic escalation type cards and
underrate some of the more generic
vegetables of the world players are
clearly better at distinguishing power
levels of simpler cards as compared to
more complex ones and this affects what
their decks look like now this point
shouldn't take s minutes to make and I
don't think this section is written as
well as it could be but the point itself
is basically fine the third section of
the video is what I would consider to be
the core of this video and it's
basically a collection of somewhat
related arguments branching off of the
concept of a deck having diverse power
levels all of these arguments are
individually pretty good IMHO and you'll
recognize elements of them repackaged
into later videos I've made choosing not
to put powerful staples into midow decks
is something that I basically made an
entire video about and I've likewise
talked about the problem with adding
random infinite combos to a deck deck
consistency is also a subject I've
talked about numerous times in the past
year and it's a core pillar of this
section of the video even when I briefly
jump back into talking about soul ring
near the conclusion of the video it's at
this point decently framed and I think
the argument I make in this section
about the card is a solid one having
variable power levels of cards in your
deck can lead to some unintended
problems and while this isn't a
blistering indictment of solver ring in
particular it at least makes sense how
silvering might fit into this sort of
argumentative framework the conclusion
to the video basically just restates a
lot of the points in the previous two
sections and seeing as how I'm okay with
most of these points individually it's
likewise fine I don't think the video
does a great job of connecting all the
various points within it but all of them
at least follow to some degree from the
core premise of the video even if that
premise is made a little murky at times
with the later Parts out of the way
let's get to the introduction the
4minute intro is easily the most
controversial part of the video and
probably the part that ended up causing
the Lion's Share of the negative
reaction the video received so how do I
feel about those arguments now well the
rhetoric is pretty bad I didn't argue
the points well above all else this is a
structure issue I simply don't really
articulate what my problem with soul
ring is in this section why is it a
problem for an extremely powerful card
to exist among much weaker cards in a
large portion of EDH decks I cover that
territory in a roundabout way later in
the video but that's not good enough for
a 22-minute YouTube video like sure if
somebody watches the entire video and
evaluates it cohesively they might have
a decent chance of catching on to what
I'm going for but look at this goddamn
graph less than half of people are still
watching when I get to the part of the
video where I start to justify my soul
ring slander now it's not objectively
bad argumentation to lead with a
controversial claim to draw people in
and give them a point of focus that can
be kind of cool actually but this video
isn't set up for that kind of rhetorical
style it makes a bold argument that soul
ring shouldn't have been reprinted with
little support or Fanfare and not much
of a framing device with which to guide
the audience to the justifying points
this is exacerbated by the slow pacing
and Bloated runtime of the second
section of the video
as it likely Burns off any sort of
tension or momentum that a controversial
argument might Garner this structuring
obviously isn't good for the reality of
people watching YouTube videos and it's
weak even for the people who fully
watched the video and charitably
interpreted its contents as many
commenters did the points about soing
simply aren't structured in a good way
to persuade people who don't already
agree with my conclusions on some level
and the fact that soling was then the
framing device for the rest of the video
predictably caused additional problems
in maintaining a cohesive Focus so
that's it right future enlightened snail
has decreed that the intro to the
problem with budget cards is bad well no
I mean it's not good let's be plenty
clear about that but my views haven't
really changed on the points I was
trying to make I don't think soul ring
should have been reprinted in commander
sets because I don't think fast Mana
belongs in casual Commander I don't have
some sort of crazy essay worth of stuff
to say in defense of that opinion I just
don't like what explosive starts do to
the tempo of games this is the argument
I should have led with in that video if
I even wanted to talk about soul ring
because it's extremely simple and
impossible to misinterpret for somebody
who isn't fully dedicated to the task of
misinterpreting it if you disagree that
fast Mana doesn't belong in casual
Commander that's fine there are valid
reasons to disagree with my thinking
here and I'm not here to change your
mind on that today I do however want to
elaborate a little on why I think not
printing soing in commander sets would
Aid in the goal of keeping fast Mana out
of casual Commander because while I
think a lot of people can follow the
chain of logic I'm gesturing at it's not
entirely trivial to start with soulring
is fast Mana a term which generally
refers to cards that are Mana positive
rituals can be a bit of a gray Zone I
generally include them if they cost no
Mana but any repeatably tapping Mana
rock that is Mana positive the turn it's
played is indisputably fast Mana these
cards are the most distinguishing factor
of cedh the thing that makes turn one or
two wins even possible and silvering
fits into this category of card to a t
with the card's fast Mana status in mind
printing Sol ring in a pre-con aimed at
getting people into the format has
symbolic power situating the card as a
casual staple that people should be
playing the fact that it was printed in
all five of the first round of precons
is all but saying dear casual Commander
players this card goes in your deck and
it being a staple isn't tied to any sort
of competitive keeping up aspect of
things mostly more on that later I
gestured at this argument when I pointed
out that the first round of precons were
quite poorly constructed but I'll make
it explicit here the decision to print
soling in every single precon since 2011
has likely had several different reasons
behind that and even if there was a
primary one it wouldn't be this sort of
keeping up idea Commander isn't a
competitive format there's nothing that
inherently requires keeping up with
rather the scarce evidence that does
exist suggests that Sol ring was
reprinted to amplify its position as a
symbol of the format to turn it into a
mascot of sorts that would be run far
and wide and be a point of connectivity
between basically all players even
though I dislike the card I can't deny
there's a certain power in that a power
that was recognized by Wizards of the
Coast in 2010 I also alluded to the
monetary motivation in the problem with
budget cards and this is almost
certainly another one of the factors
involved in printing soul ring putting a
piece of fast Mana in in every preon
absolutely helped Wizards of the Coast
sell more units they were a business
putting out a new product line and they
wanted to make sure it was successful I
was a bit smarmy about this a year ago
because it's really fun to be smarmy in
YouTube videos but the monetary element
is kind of just a fact of life in the
world we live in speaking of which let's
talk about the price argument heavily
printing soulring in commander sets has
undoubtedly kept the price of the card
low and the price of a card being low
leads more players to play it in casual
EDH a fast Mana card being $100 or $200
rather than $1 or $2 will absolutely
result in fewer people playing that card
85% of decks run soul ring but only 11%
of players run the very similar manac
Crypt and every Commander with a more
than 50% play rate of manac Crypt is
almost exclusively used in
cedh so if my goal is last fast Mana in
casual EDH and that is my general
preference not reprinting soul ring
absolutely would have accomplished that
goal to a large extent now this is
allowed to make you uncomfortable and it
makes me uncomfortable too so let's just
take a minute to sit in our discomfort
with playing a card game that is also a
network of commercialized products the
whole thing feels kind of weird huh okay
getting back into the topic at hand I
would posit that the argument I just
presented is more or less a mixture of
my preferences and a set of readily
available facts about the nature of
humans money and markets however on a
Vibes level I understand why this was a
volcanically controversial take and in
retrospect I probably wouldn't choose to
make it again a direct implication of
what I'm saying here is that I think
it's good when cards I dislike are more
expensive to keep them in fewer people's
reach and there's something kind of
harsh about that right there is an
undeniable element of inherent classism
to players with more money having access
to more cards than less weal
opponents this is most obvious when you
think about high-powered Staples as
somebody who plays mostly budget decks
you can believe that I've experienced
some fleeting pangs of frustration when
my tuned budget piles have gotten blown
out by opponents playing a series of
powerful Staples that I'm unable to keep
up with however if I may be allowed this
one Indulgence I want to give just a bit
of push back here the classism argument
is a lot weaker when it comes to EDH
compared to basically every other
constructed format in the game cedh is
very proxy friendly and for the rest of
the EDH format the Casual EDH format
there is no set power level to keep up
with lacking access to a particular
powerful card while potentially being a
subjective issue within the context of a
playgroup or table doesn't objectively
make a deck more or less ideal in any
sense now this isn't to say power level
is irrelevant players might have a
specific power level they want to play
at and if they're struggling to boost a
deck up to to that point a natural
reaction might be to for LLY gaze upon
the ristic studies and the rate henges
and the one rings of the world and ask
why they must be denied these things on
account of their wallet but the solution
of all players living in a Land of
ubiquitous Staples with 25% of a deck
immediately gobbled up by these sorts of
high-powered cards as soon as a player
picks their colors well it's garbage
there is a profound uncreative to the
proliferation of so-called must-play
Staples within the commander form
and when I hear players Pine after this
vision of the format my more callous
instincts want to interpret this as them
saying why can't I be allowed to be less
creative I certainly don't want to
Discount the feelings of players who are
struggling to win games and not having
fun because of it those people exist and
they matter but in a casual social
format I can come up with several far
better solutions to this problem than
just printing enough copies of the one
ring that everybody and their Uncle can
have one for 50 cents if you want to
play at a higher power level have a
conversation about proxying if you want
to play at a lower power level talk to
your opponents about that and if the
people you find yourself playing against
are too ordinary and inconsiderate to
spend even an ounce of effort helping
you have fun in a casual card game
format they're not worth playing
against I suppose this video wouldn't be
complete if I didn't return to the
actual question of the problem with
budget cards is there a problem with
budget cards is it bad when a card's
price in dollars or Euros or Yen doesn't
reflect its power level well I think
this is a question with a lot of layers
to it and my feelings were complicated
even a year ago despite the title
thumbnail combo the actual contents of
the video were more of a free form
ramble on the subject of cards like this
rather than being some sort of pointed
takedown so ring in particular serves as
the most dramatic example of a power
cost imbalance and the fact that one of
the most powerful Mana artifacts in the
game is run in all sorts of decks in the
range of janky and budget is a striking
thing to observe this out of placess is
what I was really trying to comment on
what does it mean when a soul ring sits
in a deck alongside a bunch of janky
Commons to some people this situation
constitutes a problem but to others the
answer to this question is a dynamic
game silvering can be a factor that adds
variance through its power level and
enables the common Jank of the world to
keep up with these sweaty optimized
piles of the oligarchs of the magic
gathering Community some might say to
put it in more mathematical terms an
injection of variance will always serve
as an equalizing Factor within games
this is true in terms of skill a new
player to Monopoly will have a better
chance against average opponents than
will a new player to chess and we can
see a parallel to this in the fact that
it's equally likely for any player at a
table to draw a soul ring we can also
think about how soul ring affects the
average power level of a deck if we
construct a 10-point power scale and put
solver ring at a 10 out of 10 a deck
whose average power level is a four out
of 10 will be more improved by a soul
ring than a deck whose average power
level is an8 out of 10 thus You could
argue that soul ring and cards that are
similarly accessible and Powerful serve
as a moderating factor between different
decks and power levels I don't find this
argument particularly compelling as a
justification for soling itself such as
my distaste for fast Mana but the
broader point is a reasonable one that
speaks to the complexity of a casual
card game format in addition there will
always be cards that are powerful
compared to their price cards see
varying numbers of copies printed and
there are a myriad of other factors that
can also serve to pump up or depress a
given card's price so with all that in
mind the answer to the question is there
a problem with budget cards is that no
there is absolutely no inherent problem
with powerful cards being cheap rather
prices of cards have an influence on
power level variants and within the
context of a social format like EDH the
cards being varying power levels poses
certain challenges to players power
level differences in cards are more
easily detectable in simpler more
mundane cards than they are for flashy
Synergy picks and players should be
careful to make sure that they end up
with the right balance of vegetables to
other stuff if your deck has a mixture
of stronger and weaker cards this will
naturally increase its variance and in
some cases that added variance might
make opponents wary if they've seen your
deck's pop off scenario before they
might Focus Focus attention on you even
when there's another deck at the table
that's more powerful overall but lower
variance these are all challenges posed
by cards having variable power levels
and navigating them can help players to
have more fun the framing device of
budget cards was one I chose to string
together these specific sets of points I
wanted to make a year ago but the
questions at the heart of the video run
much deeper than money casual formats in
any sort of game will always have an
inherent tension between more
competitive Play and play that is more
expressive and less goal oriented these
things exist on a hazy spectrum and
there's no one place on that spectrum
that will maximize fun for all people
involved in a given gamer format no
single right answer to questions on how
decks should or shouldn't be put
together at the end of the day I'm just
one guy giving you my best advice on how
to navigate that complex
World thanks for making it to the end
this is a bit different than most of
what I make so you can let me know what
you think about it I'm genuinely curious
whether this retreading of a
controversial topic Works any better for
people if you want to support me in
making videos like this you can
subscribe to my patreon for $3 a month
I'm currently taking submissions for my
August Deck review and I've also started
releasing less scripted FaceCam videos
including one about Cascade about a week
ago